you talk about rogan earlier right i
want to read the story can you pull up
this tech insider article that just came
out
which is absolutely uh and i'm going to
give you a prediction i'm going to make
a prediction here with this on what i
believe is going to happen
uh next
do you know which one i'm talking i
emailed it to you if you want to pull it
up you should have it somewhere there
uh so so folks a lot of people are not
happy with this guy named joe rogan can
you do me a favor and go to the actual
article instead of just having it that
way go to the actual article
it says uh put spotify misinformation
scientists
police
those words it should come up
uh uh uh uh the the the doctors call on
spotify to swap okay there you go here
we go we will read this
doctor's call make it a little bit
bigger so i can read it doctors call on
spotify to stop code misinformation
citing joe rogan podcast the platform is
helping damage public trust and
scientific research according to a
letter signed by hundreds of medical
professionals i believe the number is
270 by the way that scientists go a
little bit higher medical
more than 250 medical professionals have
signed an open letter caller on spotify
to clamp down on covenant's information
spreading on his platform especially
calling out the podcast of comedian joe
rogan the letter took issue with
december 31st episode of joe rogan
experience podcast when he featured dr
robert mullen an immunologist who claims
to have created the mrna technology but
is now vocal skeptic of the vaccine that
use it um
by allowing the propagation of false and
societally
harmful assertions spotify's enabling
its hosted media to damage public trust
and scientific research and so
doubt in the credibility data-driven
guidance offered by medical
professionals great words by the way the
way they awarded that sounds very legit
this is not a scientific or medical
concern it's a sociology sociological
issue of devastating
proportions and spotify islam foreign
the letter was first uh reported
wednesday by rolling stone okay so now
watch this so now they're attacking who
they're going after
rogan but they're really going after who
this is not wrong
they're going after spotify okay
so who is who who runs spotify who is
the ceo of spotify
who's the ceo spotify
pull up ceo the spotify okay and you'll
see who he is daniel eck yeah and and
what he wants to do okay
what he wants to do swedish billionaire
yeah swedish billionaire here he's 38
years old young dude and he wants to win
that game i think uh uh michelle obama's
with them podcasts kardashians i believe
is with them podcasts
they're going after all the big names
right where's obama and um uh yeah i
know
yeah here's all i'm saying to you
watch in the next week two weeks three
weeks four weeks if they go after this
guy because now he's a target okay watch
if something comes out with a me too uh
uh drug habit watch if something comes
out with his personal life you know he
lost super mario brothers when he was
18. why something comes out right he
broke up with his first girlfriend he
likes older women he likes whatever he's
into certain kinky things something's
going to come out about this guy in the
next you think there's going to be some
hit pieces are you
think about it this way for sure who
is like that whole thing would get her
right they get her twitter and joe rogan
called them out i think he said the one
of the investors and get her is what a
chinese something i don't know if you
saw that or not that he called it out so
even rogan who got them a million people
he still slammed them and it's a
georgian slam social media platform get
her call it uh uh uh uh what does it
call it for uh for gazing just days
after [ __ ] yeah okay
for gazi just days after joining go go a
little lower okay so anyway so joe logan
calls joe rogan calls
joe rogan calls out
um this new app because the investors in
the back end are chinese
but
right now silicon valley think about how
many people like our most viewed
interview on spotify
is dr malone's interview right our most
viewed interview ever on spotify is dr
malone because everybody says where can
i get it
you can go to spotify we don't have a
rumble account rumble account ceo
reached out to me we're gonna have a
conversation see what happens there but
i'm not on rumble so point being
if this happens and they're now fearing
what rogan's doing yep if
daniel stays strong
as big as spotify's they're about to
blow up even more if he stays strong
but see this this should terrify
everyone what's going on i mean and you
know i i saw that joe rogan was a target
so i started listening to him because i
was like what is this guy doing over
there that's getting so much heat
people are terrified he's just having
people on and asking questions
he's just having guests they're coming
on doctors he's asking questions he's
not telling everyone don't get
vaccinated i have never heard him say
that he's saying look i know people who
had bad side effects i know people who
didn't what's going on here with the
data you know he taught he had a video
was released the other day that i had
missed from december where he's talking
about how pharmaceutical companies
they're the only ones that retain their
raw data this is important information
and you have
americans left right and center right
now who are tired of establishment media
because yeah you know you showed that
article and it says oh all these medical
professionals hate this
who are you talking about are you
talking about big pharma allies that are
threatened by someone who's actually
asking questions to people like malone
why are you still threatened by malone
you have a million doctors sitting on
cable news all day long that for the
last year and a half have been spouting
lies and nonsense that have then we've
watched every single one of those things
be disproven
most of them have never apologized for
anything but you can't listen to dr
malone on joe rogan give his opinion and
talk about what he sees happening why is
there a shutdown so people should be
absolutely horrified by what's happening
and you know what go and listen
go
get on joe rogan show and just listen
because the same thing happened to me
you know i was shut down for
misinformation on network television i
then wrote an article i don't know if
you know this but the daily mail had
approached me i saw that they re they
took it back or something like that they
pulled it down in the middle of the
night
daily the daily mail asked me to write
an article about my stand on vaccines i
wrote the article i submitted it it was
edited like i agreed to the edits they
published it in the middle of the night
it disappears with no explanation this
is happening to people in every aspect
of media there is a shutdown of people
just asking questions
so
you know and nothing i said there i then
posted screenshots and i was like look
at what i'm saying i'm telling people to
make their own informed decision based
on their own risk benefit analysis and
their own conversations with their
doctors that's somehow threatening to
big pharma and of course it is because
big pharma is coming out with one size
fits all approaches and one size fits
all never works in medicine it never
works in health anyone who's had any
health obstacle in their life knows that
one size fits all is garbage
so
be scared you know when we were talking
about the election i remember people
talking about you know a stolen election
and i didn't buy into that because i
would they were talking about voting
machines and i was having conversations
i was on fox news at the time
with gop officials on the ground who
were telling me this is not true you
know we are republicans we are making
sure we are counting these we are
manually counting them after the stuff
you know is tallied up in the machines
this is not happening and i say now if
you're going to talk about an election
and collusion what you really should
have been talking about is this stuff
there was collusion going on between big
tech there was collusion going on
between politicians and big pharma all
of that was happening all of that was
happening that was what led to the
election changing the way that it did it
wasn't about covet it was about all of
that stuff it was about manipulation of
data it was about manipulation of
information it was about cnn's tracker
that was up the death tracker and now
suddenly is not there this was all
targeted so if you're a free speech
advocate i don't care i don't give a
damn if you're a republican a democrat a
libertarian if you are a free speech
advocate and you just want people to be
able to have their voices heard to have
their questions answered then you should
be appalled by what is going on right
now with the shutdown of voices and joe
rogan is an example of that the only
reason he's getting attention is because
he has a ton of viewers and they're like
oh my god this may convince people to
realize that they should have ownership
of their own lives and their own health
that's all it's about his viewership
puts uh msnbc cnn fox news hannity
tucker to shame i mean we had the stats
uploaded and i don't agree with him on
everything i mean joe he is pat says the
most necessary voice in america right
now he's the most he can't be possible
and and so is every individual podcast
and that's people are like getting away
from corporate media and they're
listening to people like you they're
listening to people like rogan they're
listening to all of these people who are
just telling you what they think and
having guests on and asking hard
questions that's all it's about but
science science is meant to be
questioned
and if you are opposing that
then then you're endorsing propaganda
you know you know the problem with big
pharma
is that there's no money in natural
immunity it can't be monetized
exactly so if there's no money in it why
the hell would they just encourage that
there's a lot of money in vaccines and
everything there's over 140 studies now
that confirm natural immunity natural
immunity is not new this is not a new
concept you know when i went when i was
pregnant and i went to the doctor and
she tested me you know things like
measles and chickenpox can be dangerous
if you get them when you're pregnant so
she said we're going to test you we're
going to test you for antibodies even
though i had been vaccinated for measles
when i was young i had had actually had
been exposed to chickenpox i never got
the rash but i had the antibodies she
tested me she said okay you you have the
antibodies and don't worry she didn't
say oh you have the antibodies let's
vaccinate let's give you a booster
this is not new to scientists and
there's a lot of doctors around the
country that have been outraged not
these are doctors who are vaccinated the
guy who wrote my medical exemption is
vaccinated himself these are not
anti-vac it's not a group of
anti-vaxxers these are doctors who are
saying dr malone's vaccine yes he's
vaccinated and he got caught he thought
he was gonna die he's been labeled as
anti-vaccine virtually every headline
that's come out that is absurd you know
even though he took
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you